we got like some pizza roll deep fried
so it's got to be good i mean it's deep
you know
careful
it's a square
[Music]
[Music]
pizza rolls versus bagel bites it's a
debate that's been around since the dawn
of time but what happens when you take
some of your favorite frozen pizza
snacks and make them gourmet
well today i'm facing off against one of
my favorite youtube chefs victor navares
aka internet shaquille together we're
gonna see who can take pizza rolls and
bagel bites to new heights we have two
serious judges today francis garcia is
the mastermind behind one of new york's
most creative slice shops artichoke
pizza and social media star cuisine has
taken over the internet with his new
york food reviews these guys don't mess
around when it comes to pizza so let's
see what they think of two freezer aisle
classics
victor i'm so happy you're here welcome
to peace awards happy to be here what a
privilege thank you so today is all
about childhood pizza snacks you know
bagel bites pizza rolls did you eat
those growing up absolutely both of them
bagel bites were the childhood snack and
then pizza rolls were like the drunk
college burn your mouth type stuff
that's hilarious yeah okay victor i'm so
excited so what are you making today i'm
making bagel bites today to elevate the
after school snack experience we're
gonna do a tasting menu if you will and
so we're gonna do three different bagel
bites inspired by the jingle pizza in
the morning pizza in the evening and
pizza at separate times oh my goodness
when pizza's on a bagel you have pizza i
love that i love that so i'll be making
a carbonara style pizza a pepperoni
style pizza and a white cheese style
piece ambitious and i'm hungry so let's
go okay step one or i guess step zero
was me bringing over these bagel
adjacent roll type things it turns out
everything that makes a good bagel makes
a bad bagel bite like the crunch on the
outside the chewiness so these are
actually made with all-purpose flour
instead of bread flour okay and they're
only like par baked so they're not very
dark yet so i've got two halves here and
i'm gonna top each one with a jalapeno
slice and spicy piece of thinly sliced
cheddar cheese and these are the only
ones that need to pre-bake just to
adhere the cheese to the bagels so while
those bake i'm gonna make a little
slurry here this is to make the toppings
stick to the bagel since these bagels
were baked plain and today i'm making
sesame bagels and everything bagels
sesame my favorite i knew it i did my
research so the everything bagel is the
pizza in the morning that's going to get
a little piece of high moisture
mozzarella which is going to make it
nice and bright white like the sort of
the whites of an egg and these get a
little bit of bacon as well pizza in the
evening is the jalapeno cheddar and that
is going to get a little bit of marinara
sauce and a little bit of the low
moisture mozzarella and this is spanish
chorizo this has been minced up into
that iconic like two millimeter bagel
bite cube that's gonna be so delicious
and the sesame bagels are getting
marinara sauce
a little chip of toasted garlic some
more of that low moisture mozzarella
this is a real snacky snack oh yeah i
love it and just a little bit of ricotta
and some freshly cracked black pepper
now these have to go in the oven for
just a couple of minutes and then i'm
going to top them with some of the
colder ingredients okay
all right these were ready faster than
it took to microwave them okay
now each one of these gets a little bit
of fresh toppings pizza in the morning
gets a little bit of pecorino romano
we're going for carbonara vibes or bacon
egg and cheese vibe the egg comes from
this egg yolk sauce what it's just egg
yolks cooked sous-vide at 149 for like
30 minutes and it makes this runny thick
pasteurized egg yolk sauce the spanish
chorizo one is going to get a little bit
of pickled cherry peppers supper time
i'm going to try to find the smallest
possible basil leaves and there it is
welcome to the bagel flight it only
makes sense to start with pizza in the
morning so okay shall we yes cheers
oh my gosh tastes like a bacon egg and
cheese yeah absolutely this is delicious
it's surprisingly good all right next
shall we move on to pizza in the evening
this is the one i've been covering
the jalapenos so good
oh yeah
this one is closest to an actual bagel
bite shall we round out this amuse
bouche with pizza for supper time yes
this one was really tasty but the bacon
egg and cheese that's the best one
easily stop playing i was taught to hook
them from the beginning that's why i'm a
youtuber
well that was delicious i'm truly a
conceptual girl like i really love the
fact that you came here today with a
full-on concept and i think you nailed
it i love a good concept i think that
this is too low brow for a high class
restaurant and two highbrow for a
microwavable meal so this dish is for
exactly two people and that's our judges
victor all this was amazing it blew my
mind but are you ready to see what i'm
gonna do absolutely i've been waiting
all day oh my goodness well hopefully
you'll love it i think i will
victor your bagel bites were really
delicious thank you but today i'm gonna
take on
pizza rolls
but i'm gonna try to take it up a notch
so today i'm making a pizza egg roll
stuffed with lobster we're gonna make a
gourmet i'm allergic to lobster oh no
why didn't you tell no not really
throwing you off your game gotta do
everything i can to win
how are you gonna put this together
though okay first things first i have my
wonton wrapper i'm going to put some
mozzarella down okay
without it yeah right you got to have
mozzarella and i have a low moisture
grande cheese as usual so then we want a
little bite of lobster you know chopped
finely sauteed some butter some dill
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take some of this pico that i made
this is the fusion of all fusions you
guys
speaking to my people yes yes let's
speak to them and i'm just going to add
lobster bites in here i'm going to roll
it like a super tight burrito the
technique here is impeccable this is why
you're the pro i have my deep fryer
preheated at 375 degrees
and i'm gonna drop these babies in nice
and hot and this is gonna fry
really quickly no more than like five
minutes
okay i think these are cooked look at
that wow they look sensational color me
impressed got some pecorino here i'm
gonna shave some on here for you and
you can't have your pizza rolls without
your dip wow there's your dip this is
your specialty yes that's my marinara
and i think we're ready cheers cheers to
you enjoy
oh crunk
it's a squirter
this is crazy you like it i forgot that
there was lobster in this until i fit
into it it lets you know oh yeah it lets
you know there's lobster in this just
based on your description i was
expecting like those full-sized egg roll
i was expecting it to read chinese food
but i mean she's giving pizza rolls
she's giving toasted ravioli she's
giving lobster roll like this is a
perfect combination well victor we had
two excellent dishes but it's not up to
me it's not up to you we have to go to
judges table we have friend from
artichoke pizza and kujin the internet
superstar i can't think of two better
judges let's see what they have to say
yes
you ready
first course you start with this one
this is like a little uh everything
bagel with egg
it really tastes like a bacon egg and
cheese the iconic breakfast right here
pretty soon delicious yeah all right
let's try the uh lunch meal i got over
here it's a jalapeno cheddar bagel
little pepperoni action so it's like a
lunchable yeah
good for you
it's legit spicy got a kick to it so
this one over here this looks like some
uh michelin star how you doing
it's like a white part rigato pecorino
yeah that's texture it's a good bagel
you know if you got a good bagel
anything is to taste good because that
was what matters you could put cat food
on a good bagel it's going to taste good
yeah overall i was pretty surprised you
know i used to eat pizza bagels growing
up here and there you know what i mean
don't cancel me for it you know everyone
did it i me get to college little drunk
pizza bagels never hurt nobody but these
aren't another level of class i mean
we're looking at like nine mod owns here
just pizza bagel sauce cheese they
definitely knew what they were doing you
know so you know growing up we didn't
make pizza bagels in my house but we did
make english muffin pizzas english
muffin pizza
is i think a better vehicle because it's
got the nooks and crannies yeah but this
is good this is like you know like like
my block growing up was half italian
half jewish that's what this is
[Music]
i just saw a second dish we got like
some pizza roll deep fried so it's got
to be good i mean it's deep you know
it's like an egg wall it looks like the
other one was uh
half italian half jewish this is half
chinese and half italian a little fusion
[ __ ]
careful
it's a square
oh definitely
that's delicious good stuff good stuff
i don't know who made this but they know
what they're doing looks like they
rolled it in some semolina before they
fried it tighter than your sister's ass
fresh out of the fryer very good
a lot of flavors going on cheese is
delicious a nice little pecorino shaved
over it this here i really like because
i love egg rolls i would have liked it
better with some duck sauce on the side
though some nice sweetness would have
really evened out everything that's
going on inside over there it's quality
this is a great egg roll this is a tough
one i think we got to go outside yeah
we're going to have a little sit down a
little warping talk a little walk and
talk absolutely
all right guys it's the moment of truth
what'd you guys think so i don't know
who made what but i love them both i
think they were both outrageous they
were both delicious i love the egg roll
with the lobster and the pico de gallo i
bit it a ton of stuff shot out the bagel
bites i also love them i love everything
bagels with cream cheese and they were
both great what can i say i'll take two
orders to go
yeah i agree they were both solid dishes
both cool concepts you know pizza bagels
there was a lot of complexity in there
same thing with the pizza roll you know
anything deep fried has my heart both of
them very good okay guys so who's the
winner
man it's a tough one it's a really tough
one i really like them both but you know
if i was gonna you know spend the night
at home with just one of them
the bagel bites i agree oh
unbelievable congratulations thank you i
appreciate it those are you those were
mine hey salute but yours were delicious
too oh they were they were delicious it
was just like all right i got a gun to
my head i got to pick one but they were
both really good well this was a tough
one there's nothing left to do but give
you the trophy hey the dollar the way it
is is my first investment in goal
thank you so much again for coming i
appreciate it
see you next week on peace awards
[Music]
i hate losing
i hope that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
shhh